on aussi yann de nombreux cas de
contamination massive
même identifié par tout le monde
[Musique]
allez
je te souhaite une belle journée qui va
ressembler à toutes les autres ça va
vous m'entendez j'ai une formation de
secouriste
[Musique]
on a des zombies comme existe pas en
valeur pour toi là ça c'est parfaitement
normal
[Musique]
sérieux des zombies tu te rendront les
risques de balade
il n'est pas question qu'on ouvre les
portes ma fille et l'adorent je veux
revoir en perte de 3 mais comment on va
passer à travers les unit je viens
d'avoir une idée de rouge alors pour toi
c'est ça une bd ou ce salut bande de
loosers
ty
mais je fais comment c'est comme dans
les films explorer passe par là on sera
au lycée avant que se passe t il quand
même qu'on se marre bien vers une mort
certaine c'est super marrant c'est
possible en fait
c
[Musique]
et si allen
non
[Musique]
sinon essayez une recherche avec hashtag
évacuation selphy moi je dis qu'on
mérite de disparaître
[Musique]